alors que les bombardements se
poursuivent et que la situation se
complique pour les civils bloqués
volodymyr et lens qui poursuit un son
tour des parlements aux occidentaux vous
le voyez s'il est en train de s'adresser
au moment où je vous parle aux
parlementaires
japonais le président ukrainien qui
vient de remercier le japon pour avoir
fourni une aide immédiate dès les
premières heures de cette guerre il
parlera ensuite cet après midi aux
français après cette adressé un déjà aux
élus américains israéliens britanniques
italiens le président ukrainien va donc
s'exprimer devant l'hémicycle à 15h par
visioconférence depuis le début de
l'invasion ce président s'est imposé
comme un maître de la communication
sachant parler à la fois au leader mais
aussi aux peuples comme l'expliquent
tout de suite lui au gris
évoqué la ville de gênes complètement
brûlé devant le parlement italien faire
référence au mur de berlin devant le
bundestag en allemagne
vous êtes comme derrière le mur à
nouveau ou à la religion juive devant le
parlement israélien à chaque auditoire
volodymyr helens qui adapte son discours
pour mieux frapper les esprits alors
face aux parlementaires français
aujourd'hui son intervention pourrait
bien suivre la même logique je fais le
pari qui va parler des attentats parce
qu'il me semble que les attentats c'est
ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui deux plus forts
dans l'inconscient collectif de plus
récent c'est là où il ya une communion
la plus importante du peuple français
ces derniers temps en multipliant chaque
jour les appels aux dirigeants étrangers
volodymyr zelensky a réussi à conquérir
l'opinion publique occidentale mais sur
le terrain militaire sa demande
principale reste pour l'heure lettre
morte
de créer
non no fly zone au dessus de l'ukraine
or c'est peut-être la demande la plus
importante de zelensky une no fly zone
zone d'exclusion aérienne
cette demande pourrait à nouveau être
évoquée par le président ukrainien
devant le parlement français aujourd'hui